well everyone flocking to the flamingo
the property is located in the heart of
the las vegas strip well this is what it
looked like
way back when 40s the 50s the flamingo
opened on december 26
1946 and it's kicking off its 75th
anniversary celebrations a little bit
early bianca holman is live to share
more about the milestone good morning
bianca 75 years there's a lot of history
in that hotel
yes it is 75 years of just a
fabulousness it's one of the oldest
resorts here on the strip and we've been
doing trivia all morning sherry so
heather and john they helped catch you
up so y'all are three and one right now
okay so our final question another
question for the morning
all right so true or false
there are some stained glass windows
that are in the front that were a part
of the original
hotel back in the 40s is that true or
false okay guys help me out i feel like
i'm on the price is right
help me out guys
original structures
yes
i i'm gonna say yes that would make
perfect sense to me yeah yes
so true yes true
okay so uh sherry that is false there is
nothing original
oh god
there is nothing original they've
demolished it they've redone it
throughout the years it's been renovated
so as right now there's no
original piece of the original hotel
we're out here in the wildlife preserve
we're going to actually
come back with that but i want to share
some more information about the history
of this fabulous hotel that sits in the
middle of the strip
so again last half hour we learned that
there was the 1960s version of ocean's
11 that was filmed here along
so it's very popular in movies
the 1960s version featured five las
vegas
featured five other las vegas casinos
that were robbed by characters played by
dean martin frank sinatra sammy davis jr
and others and this is a historical
property as it sits right in the middle
of the strip the resort was also
featured in the 1991 film of bugsy the
design of this property was before its
time many early hotels had a ranch type
feel the flamingo was more elevated art
deco cosmopolitan style
cosmopolitan style very high class so
the resort now offers more than 3
thousand rooms and suites they've got
renovated rooms and of course a unique
bunk bedroom as well
so you can see that we're out here at
the wildlife area habitat area this
property has also been through several
ownership since 1946 which includes the
hilton and now caesars entertainment so
you can tell we're out here with the
flamingos that are a classic and iconic
recognizable part of the hotel so last
question hopefully all of you all are
there at the desk
when did they open the preserve and the
wild habitat that's out here right now
what year
like they feel like nate might know that
18.65 i'm going to say i'm going to say
2011.
all right a little more modern okay any
other responses nate what do you think
um
i'm going to say 95.
i'll go with 98.
okay
it's gotta be somewhere in the 90s
one dollar
okay one dollar john
all right nate you're correct 1995.
you're correct and if you come out here
come out here you'll not only see the
flamingos they got other birds and other
wildlife that's out here and also it's
the holidays so you know they have their
christmas decorations out always
something to see and we've got more
information about the history of the
flamingo and all that they're doing to
celebrate 75 years the oldest resort
still here on the strip back to you guys
in the studio hope you had fun give
yourself a go start for participation
good good stop